may I see my monitor really quick for a
second to check my hair all wild looks
great very nice Wow even better than I
thought
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from 14 of Pizza in DeKalb Market Hall
where I'm joined by Anthony Falco and
Andrew W K Anthony is an international
pizza consultant the former pizzas are
at Roberta's Andrew you know from hits
like party hard she is beautiful
the new album you're not alone this out
now and today what we're gonna be doing
is the ultimate party hack we're gonna
be recreating two of Pizza Huts most
iconic menu items cutting out the
middleman
no delivery charge today we do it all
ourselves but before we fire up the oven
Andrew your pizza credentials their vast
you have a pizza electric guitar keynote
speaker at the Chicago pizza summit the
professor of partying so I need to know
what's the difference between a pizza
party and just eating a pizza by
yourself is there a difference zero
difference
zilch difference it's the same thing
every party is a pizza party even if
there isn't pizza there even if there
aren't other people there even if
there's just a pizza sitting alone in a
room that pizza is having a pizza party
by itself all right today we're going in
the time-machine we're traveling back to
the 90s Pizza Hut's heyday what did they
get write about pizza back in the day
the affiliation with Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles
thank you comes up yes that was awesome
I feel like they had the best mozzarella
and they had the most buttery
golden-brown crust that was like really
the best thing what the hell happened I
mean I think just there's been a race to
the bottom with ingredients well today
we're reversing course it's gonna be a
childhood staple we're doing pan Pizza
Pizza Hut style we're also doing stuffed
crust pizza hutt style and then we're
gonna do something the world has never
seen before we're gonna have to stick
around for that exciting development
ready to get started I'm ready let's go
in here we are with Pizza Hut's greatest
hit it's the pan pizza what makes this
special I put a lot of fat in there so
there's olive oil and then there's
actual butter in the dough real butter
in the dough first thing we're gonna do
is define the crust because if you
remember in the pizza pan pizza there
was this really nice ring of crust
there was very little sauce in a pizza
hi Pizza something to keep the massive
amounts of cheese to the dough and we've
got two different kinds of mozzarella
here this is fresh mozzarella that I
pulled from Kurt and then I've got kind
of a low moisture pizzeria shredded
cheese here and now over here we have
pepperonis at what point is a pepperoni
piece to become a pepperoni lover's
pizza I think you wins the pita inside
that stop sign and as soon as you start
peddling doubling up on pepperonis like
there's a pepperoni layer and then
there's one on top of that you're in the
lovers okay good the pepperoni lover's
lane right that looks nice you got kind
of like a supreme situation yeah veggie
lovers pepperoni lover's yeah here we
are pan pizzas fresh out the oven and if
I'm on an eyeball test I'm impressed
with us I mean everyone did really well
I'm gonna go ahead and crown Andrew the
winner here with this beautiful
pepperoni lover's yeah but I mean all of
these we're all winners really yeah
party no losers at the pizza party and
then off smell what's interesting is it
has sort of a french toast quality to it
it's a lot of butter in there there's a
lot of butter but it just smells great
it looks great and then the bottom
there's the real pizza hunt a straight
golden brown and delicious I'd say oh
there it is
we've got a bear it it in a slight
moisture - yeah cheers boys mmm oh no
the dole fantastic we really did reverse
engineer the best of pizza hut every
bite is like 1995 Andrew looks like you
having an out-of-body experience ever
had better pizza come on Wow it's also
unique no I'm not exaggerating I'm not
just saying that for this show I'm kind
of taking it back that's why I'm kind of
having a moment to myself because when
these moments come you have to recognize
them you have to stop an internally
experience and show gratitude or you
won't get them again it's disrespectful
to not acknowledge this level of
euphoria
and it's coming from the inside out and
we need a picture of Pepsi Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles in time video game
machine yep it'll combat and it's like
we're young again
all right now the pizza chain business
it's dog-eat-dog and if you recall in
the 90s everybody was doing weird sorts
of things and Pizza Hut especially their
grand slam was really in the stuffed
crust pizza and that's what we're making
right now how do we start because this
is gonna be much more of a challenge
than the pan pizza I expect good
instincts it's gonna be a challenge so
I've tried to do it many times oh it's
always been kind of a huge failure so
I'm really hoping this time around I've
learned from some of these mistakes and
we can execute it so this is what you
would do if you were making a pizza
normally as you define the crust like
that but because we're doing stuffed
crust we're just gonna flatten the edge
out too and we're gonna get like a flat
disc and then pick it up and it's kind
of like a back and forth kind of thing
you guys feeling comfortable about with
this yeah I'm feeling a little uneasy
and insecure yeah but that's not about
the pizza that's just yeah I mean I'm
watching Sean and I'm like your elbows
shot up with kind of a football shaped
yeah you got the ball shape and you also
have a thin spot in the middle and like
a little too thick on the edge you want
to flatten this edge out and kind of
finish doing it without getting in the
middle at all like if you can work the
hedges kind of like this you can grow
the edges a little bit I'm not doing
very well but I'm glad he's ignoring me
again similar situation thin middle and
the edges we're gonna flatten out
because we're stuffing the crust we
really want to get it flattened out on
the edge a little bit
our dough's are stretched they're flat
it's time for a swap in are we ready to
stuff our crust yes yeah I made string
cheese last night I took fresh
mozzarella just shaped it into like
playdough shapes it into snakes snakes
so I think the key here is that we're
gonna want to get a good seal if we can
make it into a pizza that comes out of
the oven I'm gonna be pretty surprised
Sean I'm loving your your crimping I
mean you've made a pie before now we can
make it a top it
let's kick it up a little bit we got
some garlic butter here and I'm low just
gonna brush the crowd where does that
come from right whoa
did I mention I've only ever [ __ ] up
what I've made this before in the past
stuff crust it's out of the oven let's
pop it up for an eye test do these
puppies it's like when we pop those pan
pizzas out it really looked like a pizza
hut pan pizza yes this is more of a
Frankenstein yeah I've never seen a
pizza that looks like this but that's
not to take away from the taste because
it might be delicious still lovable to
test the stuffed crust we have to eat it
backwards it's oozing our duty yeah I'd
say our biggest failure here is you've
got some leakage
it's burst the levee and it started to
get into the center where we already had
a lot of cheese we did not need more
what do you think Pizza Hut was doing
that they're able to get that quality
control on stuffed crust for all those
years
probably it was frozen by being frozen
by the time the crust was finished
cooking then the mozzarella inside would
be just the right temperature of like
stretching and pulling without running
out it doesn't matter cuz you're gonna
fit all runs together it's all good
ingredients they're all in one place and
they all are going to the same place
which eventually is the toilet I guess
in a respectful way Pizza Hut and chains
in general they've gotten very daring
with their offerings so today what are
we doing to just go out there to just
get weird with it Pizza is undisputably
the most fun food in the world but it's
the second most in my opinion would be
tacos and Andrew I know you've got a
pizza guitar yes and you also have a
taco guitar that is right because I feel
exactly the same way these are the two
parties foods in the world crossed with
the partyís instrument or at least the
most portable party instrument guitar so
why not have an electric taco pizza
guitar why not have an electric pizza
guitar and why not make an electric taco
pizza well all that inspiration in mind
we are going to be making a taco pizza
with nacho bite crusts ooh
I'm gonna start in the middle with some
whipped cream whoa it it has lime zest
in it it's a great way to apply a creamy
base but have it not run all over the
place because as everyone knows pizza is
flat
he's just sweet like whoa there's I just
didn't add sugar I added salt and lime
zest and it's gonna give it kind of like
limey creamy base or the chorizo to sit
into so I've got some jalapenos which I
pickled yesterday I'll I have my own
recipe because I feel very strongly
about jalapeno so now I've got my
refried black beans I'm gonna do little
dollops around the edge right a lot of
pizza purists might be rolling in their
graves seeing something like that I
think I'm losing followers right now
you're scoring the crust I mean I think
this is how it's done
I don't know so then we're gonna like
we're gonna make like a little star
pattern this is fancy yes a little nacho
bite is this indicative of what pizza
makers do after hours this the kind of
experimenting that goes right during
hours if we're high enough
how weird have you gotten with this
before I've done a lot of drugs and made
pizzas on acid one time I put peeps on a
pizza that was a terrible idea take a
look at the eye test so excited to see
this come out and keep its shape I mean
it yeah it works it's a taco pizza I'm
gonna finish it now with a few more
ingredients I'm gonna add some fresh
cilantro on there and the whole thing
some lime pickled onions which are
really nice some sour cream the lattice
pattern Wow Wow
craziness I feel like we went back in
time only to travel into the future
getting real year 3,000 with this one Oh
oh my gosh we either made the greatest
party food of all time
or an abomination one abomination again
oh wow the flavors are really there no
lime it is you have some sweetness you
have some heat creaminess creaminess is
in there it just tastes like a party
taste change as you bite down the butt
of the slice you got different things
each to each in each bite and then you
get to the nacho bite
that's here's their case good it's just
confusing like I'm eating nachos but I'm
not done a lot of messages these pizzas
that have never been done before at
least by us yeah and I would say we were
at least two for three yes three I'm
concerned Andrew what did you learn
today I had all my highest hopes and
fantasies exceeded and I had my belief
in pizza power once again confirmed
thank you very much yes
[Music]
does it play any differently the pizza
guitar the taco guitar the pizza guitars
a little cheese here and the taco
guitars little beefier time